the capital Gazette's owners
establishing a fund for victims families
and survivors of last week's deadly
shooting rampage in Annapolis Maryland
for journalists and a sales assistant
were killed in the attack on the papers
newsroom
chip Reid spoke with one survivor that's
photographer Paul W Gillespie in an
interview that you'll see only on CBS
this morning you're wearing a shirt that
says journalism matters today more than
ever it does you wore that for a reason
yeah I want everyone to see it what do
you what's your message by wearing it
support local journalism subscribe to
the paper we're not evil we're just
regular working people trying to tell
stories from our communities
you know like ice like at dividuals he's
I don't know if you saw but like we got
a lot of love around here you know
everyone knows I stayed under we're not
I'm not trying to do bad things we're
trying to tell her stories local SP
calls a paper an important part of the
community and says it's important to
keep going after the attack you can hear
more chips conversation with Capitol
Gazette survivor Paul Gillespie on our
CBS s morning podcast it's available on
Apple's podcast app or other podcast
platforms it was clear he told chip that
he really thought he was going to die
hiding under a desk next to a colleague
who did die and I saw an interview with
a survivor that said they feel more more
now than ever as he just said that we're
going to continue to do our job how
important what they do is yeah exactly
really important